let's check in right now with Kelty
night because she has a health update
from Alex Trebek and it sounds like it's
good news Kelty which is of course good
to hear yes it is keV the Jeopardy host
letting us know he can still do the job
he loves so much I'm doing well I've
been continuing my treatment and it is
paying off though it does fatigue me a
great deal
Alex assured fans he's making progress
in his Stage four pancreatic cancer
battle my numbers are good I'm feeling
great the 79 year old is still working
taping a few elements at home for an
upcoming special four week jeopardy
retrospective series beginning this
month including the very first Jeopardy
show I ever hosted you have to be very
bright in order to participate on our
show he was on set for that episode back
in 1984 nearly 36 years later
Alex's mustache is back with a goatee
and so are his hopes to return
I can't wait to return to the studio and
start recording shows for the new season
in September
[Music]